[Music]
and let's move on to something a little
bit more exciting
exciting like an app with a plot so this
application here is
pretty similar but now when i change
this slider
it's going to change i think the number
of bins that go into computing this
histogram so you can see as i
increase the number of bins
this histogram is going to have more
stagger to it so yeah this one has a
slightly more
complex user interface
and notice as i make the window wider
this actually looks a little bit more
like a sidebar than it does um
like an intro
input panel or something like that
so that's
this sort of functionality is provided
by this layout sidebar
from the ui sub package
so with the layout sidebar it really
wants like a sidebar panel
and a main panel
and uh so on the left hand side here i
have the slider similar to what we had
before
um another output text verbatim on the
right hand side in the main panel and
then a plot underneath that and this
example
starts to introduce some reactivity
concepts
so with this at reactive.calc
this is a decorator for
defining
a calculation that depends on some input
values and then returns another value
from some combination of input values
so this is like over overly simplistic
example that just reads the
slider value
and then multiplies it by two
and gives this reactive calculation a
name of r so once i have this function
defined as a reactive calculation
then i can read it just like i would
read an input value
inside of another reactive context like
this rendered text output
so
this is you know for all
real um practical purposes this is
essentially the same as just
you know putting this
expression into
the read of r
but for more
sort of sophisticated reactive
um
web applications
this is a really useful construct for
you know encapsulating like a chunk of a
reactive calculation whether it's you
know
performing performing a data summary
or
you know computing a model from some
data
it's always a good idea to kind of
put those steps into reactive
calculations basically it gives shiny
more information to do less work when it
makes sense to do less work
so if you have like a big you can define
like a big reactive chain with like
several calculations that depend on each
other and if
one of those calculations gets
invalidated because the value is out of
date for whatever reason shiny knows to
not go back all the way to the top of
that graph and recompute everything it
can kind of just say
i just need to do the last two
calculations and then
knows to do less work
when it makes sense to that is reactive
calculations in a nutshell
and then
to start showing you some different
variations on rendering different types
of objects into ui
here's an
at.renderplot and
these decorators can actually be used
without parentheses or with parentheses
you can call it like a function
and that's particularly useful for
something like render plot which has
additional arguments that you can
specify like
some alt text to put on this image to
make it more accessible then
you know you use it just like how you
would a render text you define a
function and you can give this function
a name
which should match an id in the user
interface
and then inside of this function
definition
i can do something like use matplotlib
to create a histogram
where
the number of bins in this histogram
comes from the value of the slider at
least currently the way render plot
works
you're going to want to always return a
matplotlib object and then we'll know
how to render
that object into an image
i do also want to mention this render
plot has the ability to understand more
than just matplotlib objects
and
i've actually whipped up this um
example app to demonstrate that so i've
at least laid out a few different
packages here but this is not
render plot is not limited to just these
packages
essentially any package that builds on
matplotlib or pill
will be
supported through render plot a lot of
what a lot of these packages will do
will essentially build on matplotlib
like plot nine which actually gives like
a more like a ggplot2 type interface to
creating graphics and they'll
essentially like subclass a matplotlib
object meaning like
they are a special form of a of a
matplotlib object
so as as long as your object kind of you
know subclasses matplotlib in some way
render plot should be able to handle it
so here's a plot nine
graph that i've um
in the shiny application i've programmed
to allow you to change like x variable y
variable and color
we also support like seaborn
you might be familiar with pandas
plotting interface where you can
essentially like from your data frame
object
called dot plot on that data frame
object
and that will return i think in like
every case a matplotlib object so you
can just basically call dot plot and
return that value and render plot should
handle that
there's also like hollow views which
supports all these different you know it
also has interactive
visualization capabilities but you can
also use matplotlib
with hollow views
xray
and geopandas
so lots of different packages out there
that
build luckily build on top of that
plotlib and you can all use
with render plot so just to give you
like a quick
idea of what i mean there so this is
actually the source code
for
that application that we are looking at
so here's a render plot with seaborne
that's creating the scatter plot
with the kernel density estimate
on top of it
plot9 was the more ggplot2 like
interface here where i'm reading like an
x input value and a y input value
so whenever those change shiny will know
to
re-execute this this function
as i mentioned with pandas there's like
a dot plot so you can call that and
return whatever that returns
hollow views it's a little bit less
straightforward there's like this render
function from hollow views
that
takes in a back end argument so as long
as you specify i want to use matplotlib
then you can use it with render plot
x array is kind of similar to pandas in
the sense that
um
it kind of has like a similar dot plot
like
interface from its special data
structure
um
and that also returns matplotlib objects
again geopanda is a lot like pando
pandas where you can just call like dot
plot
um
and then missing no
i think also returns
matplotlib object
this matrix
function here
[Music]